no shortages of flour and baking powder
but supply chain problems are making
life hard it's getting very sticky now
there's a prime minister who likes to
have his cake and eat it but fuel and
food disruption caused by the pandemic
and brexit threatened to sour the mood
in manchester
and beyond into winter fantastic nothing
can get wrong a very confident
prediction that this christmas will be
considerably better than last week well
that was a low bar because we didn't you
cancelled it last year it's just telling
you it's gonna it's gonna be much would
that be disruption could there be empty
shelves i think i think we're gonna we
have very this country leads the world
actually in in logistics and supply
chains we've got very good supply chains
uh where there are issues that we can
help with we'll do everything we can
but batting away questions is easier
than batting away actual problems
ministers promise they will be dealt
with soon we are dealing with those
those issues about use but you can't
promise me that there's going to be
turkey there's going to be turkey and on
the table at christmas can you we may we
will make sure that people have their
turkeys for christmas and i know that
the the environment secretary george
justice this is absolutely top of his
his list the fast conservative gathering
since that landslide election victory
and boris johnson got brexit done this
was supposed to be a celebration of the
political spoils of victory but instead
the hangover of the pandemic and brexit
loom large fears over fuel shortages and
feeding our families at christmas
threatened to overshadow this conference
so far the government haven't paid a
political price for the disruption but
anxiety is growing
ministers blame disruption on factors
beyond their control the pandemic
pent-up demand volatile global markets
[Music]
but whatever's responsible for getting
us here the public will look to the
government to get us out beth rigby sky
news manchester